let's talk about racist formerly
convicted but now pardoned by trump
sheriff joe arpaio he's running for
Senate he's 85 years old and he will
just not go away this is the guy who was
known while he was sheriff of Maricopa
County for just outrageously poor
treatment of inmates and he eventually
lost his position as sheriff he then was
convicted of criminal contempt because
he denied or ignored a court order to
stop racially profiling Latinos in
Maricopa County
he was almost immediately pardoned by
Donald Trump who I guess just loves
sheriff Joe and Sheriff Joe took to
Twitter of all places to announce that
quote I am running for the US Senate
from the great state of Arizona he does
the same thing as Trump with random
capitalization great state of Arizona
capitalized great and state for one
unwavering reason to support the agenda
and policies of President Donald Trump
in his mission to make America great
again
does Sheriff Joe have a shot I don't
think so
this is the seat to replace outgoing
Senator Jeff Flake Kelly Ward is already
running a congresswoman martha mcsalley
is expected to enter the race any day
and then you've got sheriff joe and
outgoing Senator Jeff Flake was asked
about it he said it's not going to last
long quote write about it fast because
it won't last long now I would normally
say like in a normal sensible world I
would say Jeff Flake is Right Arpaio has
no shot but Trump won and Arpaio is the
Trump candidate so I I don't want to do
that thing where I say the guy has no
shot whatsoever
almost every Republican who voted in
Alabama voted for an alleged serial
child sex assault or so I'm not gonna
write off Sheriff Arpaio and the whole
reason that Jeff Flake is leaving is
because he's become too moderate he
probably would have been not have been
able to win that Republican nomination
that maybe so the person who's probably
gonna win it is gonna be someone on the
far right I'd imagine you think this
might just be a stunt Arpaio trying to
raise money and then use it for
something else it's just it's very hard
for me to imagine that 85 year old Joe
Arpaio really wants to be a senator and
to start traveling back and forth
between Washington DC and Arizona
constantly no I believe it I think he's
just that full of himself right that's
why he keeps putting himself back into
the spotlight I don't know I really
don't know it's just it's difficult to
believe I think that the most likely
scenario is kind of like Trump he's
running because he thinks it would be
good for publicity but doesn't have a
chance to win of course
according to Michael Wolf's book that
led to Trump's entire family crying
after they found out that old Trump
became president of the United States on
November whatever the date was 2016 I
don't even remember now I don't know I
don't know what to tell you but my
advice to my friends in the great state
capitalized great state of Arizona don't
vote for this guy and if and some of you
are Republicans vote for somebody else
well it would be interesting if he does
win the Republican nomination and then
you alienate so many of those voters in
the middle oh that it goes maybe there's
a path for a Democrat to win I remember
even back in the 2016 election it was
contentious Hillary Clinton had a shot
at that at one yeah that is what I would
call the dream scenario and I would not
count on that necessarily by no means